all right it's been a very very big week
and much has happened we have a new
president we have a new vice president
donald trump
fled washington d.c and shame on
wednesday
all very exciting and many people want
to comment so let's go
to what we call the phone lines even
though they're really more like internet
tubes at discord davidpakman.com
discord let's go to our friend scott
from pensacola even though
every time i the last time we went to
scott from pensacola i have a friend
scott in pensacola he's never actually
called in it's some other scot in
pensacola
scott in pensacola you're on the air yes
you got me
yeah excellent
so the inauguration
yesterday um what do you make about uh
them i guess the people on the right
um crying about how garth brooks decided
that he wanted to show up for
joe biden but had a scheduling conflict
last time
i couldn't care less yeah i mean listen
i i mentioned this during the live
stream earlier this week of the
inauguration
where in 2016 in 2017 trump wanted garth
brooks
and garth brooks said sorry i have a
scheduling conflict and it wasn't really
clear whether he did
and then garth brooks was invited this
week and he said i'm doing it and i'm
doing it as a unity statement not as a
political statement
and of course many of us wondered was it
really a scheduling conflict in 2017 or
did he simply not want anything to do
with
donald trump i don't know the answer but
to the extent that right-wingers are
focused on it
i don't care it's such a minor issue
do you think you was successful in
making a unity statement with it
i was garth brooks successful or was the
biden inaugural
a strong unity statement
uh the inaugural more so yeah i mean i
listen here here's the thing
joe biden did so much more
on wednesday than he anyone deserved
given the divisive and weaponized
disinformation nature of the last four
years
now given that biden did it
is it likely that we're now going to
have unity with these obstructionist
republicans
no but biden did it just because it
won't work because the republicans won't
go for it doesn't mean biden was wrong
to say
let's come together and i'm everybody's
president so i think biden did a good
job i don't think it'll go anywhere
and one last question before i'll let
you go what do you think
just sort of as a normal person
um i can do or generally people
in the audience can do to kind of keep
um
colleagues or friends from sort of
tuning out and going to brunch
as i've heard it put i mean i think i
think the the most important message
is nothing's happened yet biden
now can do stuff but nothing's happened
yet and of course he's gotten some
executive orders done so things are
starting to happen but
i think the message needs to be the last
four years we didn't even have a shot at
getting anything done now we have a shot
at getting things done but
imagine that whenever you get the ball
back in football you stop playing
because you think you score points
by getting the ball you would be very
wrong once you get the ball you've got
to score the points that's where we are
now
gotcha well thanks for your time my
pleasure scott from pensacola
always great to hear from our friends in
pensacola
one of our sponsors today is trivia star
a
free trivia game for mobile devices with
over 60 different
trivia categories including things i
know
you would love like geography history
science
many other great topics movies sports
food i've been having a bunch of fun
with it because
i as the player get to choose the
category
so i'm only answering questions on
topics i'm interested in
there are over a thousand different
levels to progress to
over ten thousand different questions
which get harder over time so it gets
more and more interesting as you play
if you love trivia like i do i remember
the day's pre-virus of going out to
trivia at a bar
and you want a fun way to keep yourself
sharp check it out
really well designed game 4.9 star
rating and the number one rated mobile
trivia game in the world
it's totally free just go to the apple
and android app store
and search for trivia star